David Boder: [In English] Spool 9-143A and 9-143B. Mr. Suvalkaitis and Mrs. Bronė Skudaikienė, respectively. October 7th 1950, Chicago, Boder. 143A in Lithuanian, 143B partly in Lithuanian, partly German.
David Boder: Spool 143. Spool 143. Munich, September the 21st 1946 at Lohengrinstrasse, in a camp for displaced Baltics—Lithuanians, Latvians and Estonians. The interviewee is Mr. Andrius Suvalkaitis, 41 years old [incorrect], Lithuanian. He will speak German.
David Boder: [In German] Sie werden Deutsch sprechen, nicht wahr?
David Boder: [In English] Of course it is not his language, but we will do the best we can.
David Boder: [In German] Also, Herr Suvalkaitis, wollen Sie nochmal sagen, wie heißen Sie, und wo sind Sie geboren und wie alt sind Sie?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Ich war geboren in Vilkaviškis erste 1915 Jahre, erstes Kind geboren.
David Boder: Also, welche Monat ist das?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: 1 April
David Boder: 1 April?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Ja.
David Boder: Und wo waren Sie, Herr Suvalkaitis, wenn der Krieg angefangen hat?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Wenn der Krieg angefangen, ich war in Kaunas.
David Boder: Also wollen wir sagen so: zuerst sind doch zu Ihnen die Sowjets gekommen, nicht wahr?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Die Sowjets wenn sie kommen bei uns in Litauen, ich war auch in Kaunas. Wir haben gehabt ein Dienst in eine Büro—Beamter.
David Boder: Als was- als was haben Sie gehabt den Dienst?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Ich hatte gehabt als die—eine—Abteilungsleiter.
David Boder: In was für einem Büro?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Das war in litauische Militär in Kauno komendantūra.
David Boder: Waren Sie Soldat?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Ich war Oberfeldwebel.
David Boder: Sie waren Oberfeldwebel?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Ja.
David Boder: Und dann sind die Sowjets gekommen. Was hat das denn passiert?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Wenn die Sowjets gekommen erst alle unsere—alle unsere Militärersten gemacht eine Corps, und alle diese Korpsobersten geschickt nach Irland.
David Boder: Die Russen haben ein Korps gemacht?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Die russische gemacht ein Korps, weil die litauische gar nicht in Militär. Und unsere Ersten noch gewarten in Kaunas eine Liquidationskommission. In diese Kommission ich auch erst gearbeiten—bis 23-igste Februar.
David Boder: Also 23.Februar, welches Jahr?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Das war 41, Jahr.
David Boder: Und, wie haben Sie gelebt, wenn die Russen in Litauen waren? Wilna war doch Poland, nicht wahr?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Ja, die war Polen.
David Boder: Aber ich dachte, die Stadt Wilna...
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Ja, das war litauische Stadt.
David Boder: Aber, bevor die Russen gekommen sind, haben doch die Polen gehabt, nicht wahr?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Ja, das die Polen erst gehabt.
David Boder: Und dann haben die Russen Wilna zurückgegeben zu Litauen.
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Ja, das bestimmt.
David Boder: Und ist jetzt Wilna in Litauen?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Ja, es ist auch in Litauen. Aber jetzt die ganze Litauen ist sowjetische...
David Boder: Sowjetische.
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Ja.
David Boder: Aber die Polen haben nicht Wilna.
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Nee, jetzt haben nicht.
David Boder: Also weiter, was hat denn passiert?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Ja, das war. Und dann die ersten Abblasen—beim Militär—bei Kommission erste alles in Ordnung gemacht- und dann in 25. Februar die ersten gesperrt in Gefängnis—die Bolschewisten. [To the reader: In German, this passage does not make any sense at all, it is just fragments.]
David Boder: Warum?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Warum? Ich weiß nicht warum. Ich habe gar nicht gemacht. Bei ersten ich war nur ein bestimmender Büro-Beamter—war nicht mehr. Und dann die ersten gesperrt—die ersten geschicken nach Kaunas—dritte in Kaunas gefangen—und dann, wer er gar nicht gemacht für mich gericht—er ab zu wenig—gar nicht.. [To the reader: In German, this passage does not make any sense at all, it is just fragments. This is why they are switching to Lithuanian afterwards.]
David Boder: Herr Suvalkaitis, sprechen Sie Litauisch. Sprechen Sie Litauisch oder Polnisch?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Litauisch.
David Boder: [In English] Okay, go ahead.
Andrius Suvalkaitis: [In Lithuanian] Tai jie mane dvidešimt penktą vasario areštavo, patalpino Kauno kalėjime. Kauno kalėjime sėdėjau, bet kadangi ten buvo per mažas įrodymas, negalėjo sudaryt man teismo, per maža buvo įrodymų, tai jie mane tardė gana ilgai—kas antra, trečia naktis iškviesdami tardymui. Iš karto tardė tardytojas rusas, vėliau žydas, pagaliau lietuvis. Bet nė vienas tardytojas iš manęs negalėjo nieko ištraukt rimto. Kadangi paro...įrodymų trūko, matydami, kad negalės sudaryti man teismo, jie paėmė mane ir išsiuntė į Vilniaus kalėjimą, tūkstantis devyni šimtai keturiasdešimts pirmais birželio trečią dieną. Ir pagaliau palaikę Vilniaus kalėjime tris dienas nusiuntė į Minską. Minsko kalėjime tikėjaus, kaip ir visi kiti teisiamieji, arba suimtieji, kuriems negalėjo sudaryt teismo, sulaukt už akių sprendimo penkiolikos, dešimties, daugiau ar mažiau metų katargos ir būt išsiųstas į Sibiro teiges. Bet laimė, tuo momentu tūkstantis devyni šimtai keturiasdešimt pirmais metais birželio dvidešimt antrą dieną kilęs karas, ir birželio dvidešimts ketvirtą dieną užskridę vokiečių aviacijos lėktuvai bombardavo Minską, ir pataikė viena bomba į kalėjimą. Kadangi ta bomba krito ant kalėjimo kampo, kalėjime kilo didelė panika.
David Boder: [In Russian] Это была немецкая бомба?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Немецкая бомба.
Andrius Suvalkaitis: [In Lithuanian] Kalėjime kilo didelė panika. Visi kalėjimo sargai, enkavedistai, prižiūrėtojai puolė lakstyt po kalėjimą, visus suimtuosius išvarė lauk į kiemą. Kurie buvo nuteisti daugiau ar mažiau, visus iki vienam ir be teismo visus kalinius suvarė į kiemą. Kieme girdėjos ir koridoriuj šaudymas. Kalėjime visus nuteistuosius mirt arba didelėm bausmėm, sušaudė kalėjimo kieme, suvarę į antrą pusę. Mus visus sustatė į tvorą žiūrint, iškėlus rankas aukštyn, ir tuo momentu vaikščioj aplinkui visokie sargai enkavedistai ir šaukė. Mes manėm, kad ir mus tam kieme sušaudys, bet vėliau iš jų skaitymo kiek buvo galima suprast, atskaitė mus apie tūkstantį du šimtus žmonių—mūsų tarpe buvo daugiausia lietuvių, buvo dalis lenkų, keletas latvių,—ir varė visus gilyn į Rusi.. į Rusiją pėsčius. Ėjom pėsti tris paras, tris dienas ir tris naktis, maža valgę ir beveik nemigę. Valgyt gavom tik tą, ką enkavedistai išmesdavo iš mašinų, patys valgę. Iš paskui važiavo mašinos, mašinose važiavo enkavedistai, enkavedistai keitėsi pamainoms—kuomet vieni pavargdavo, sėsdavosi į mašinas, kiti eidavo. Pražygiavus gerą galą vienam miškely—miškelio pavadinimo dabar aš neprisimenu—buvo toks kaip ir postovis. Pailsėt davė tik tokiu momentu, kada krito minia ir negalėjo paeiti—didesnė pusė krisdavo, tada mums leisdavo šiek tiek pailsėt. Pagaliau tam miškely sušaudė gana daug žmonių, ir likusius visus varė tolyn. Pagaliau trečią dieną pavakariais pražygiavus pro Červenę prie vieno miškelio netolimai upelio panašaus į lietuvišką Nevėžį gilumo ir sriaunumo atžvilgiu, ir prie to upelio leido atseit poilsį. Ir tam poilsy—a mes kaip sykis nešėm kartu dviejuos—aš ir dar vienas prietelis pulkininką Petruitį—ant rankų, ir mes sumerkėm vis kojas į tą upelį, kad atgaut bent kiek, šiek tiek...atgaivint kraują, nes buvom privargę, nevalgę, išalkę ir be to, nuo tardymo iškankinti. Mano asmeniškai kojos buvo sudaužytos čia taip, kad vos į kelnes tilpo. Tuo momentu antrasis prietelis, kuris stovėjo, man sudavė per petį ranka ir pasakė—žiūrėk, Andriau, į užpakalį. Kuomet aš atsisukau į užpakalį pamačiau įstatytus aplinkui kulkosvaidžius. Ir po to mano tų enkavedistų vadas sukomandavo stot visiem ir gult. Po šito momento prasidėjo šaudymas. Sušaudė mūsų visą minią, kiek mūs buvo ten. Laimei, ant manęs iš karto užkrito negyvi lavonai. Buvo toks, matyt, laimės momentas, likimas—mes visi trys kai buvom, ir sugulėm į tokią vagą. Sugulėm visi, ir laimei krito ant mūs lavonai, paskiau tas egzekucija tęsėsi maždaug tris valandas. Po trijų valandų nurimo, nutilo kulkosvaidžių šaudymai, pasigirdo vaikščiojimas, keiksmas rusiškas enkavedistų, ir gyvus, kurie nebuvo visiškai nušauti, durtuvais subadė galvas arba kastuvėliais suskaldė pakaušius žmonėms. Po šito visai nurimus jiems, kada jau pasidarė tyla, pradėjo, aš pradėjau judintis, nes ant manęs kuomet gulėjo dvylika lavonų, aš buvau kraujy pasruvęs visas. Apie mane nieko nebuvo daugiau
išskiriant svetimo kraujo. Tuo momentu aš pasijudinau, numečiau pirmuosius lavonus nuo galvos, pakėlęs galvą apsidairiau, ar nesimato kas nors,—nieko nesimatė, tik tuščias lavonų laukas. Tuo momentu aš pakėlęs galvą atsisėdau, pradėjau šaukt, pradėjau šaukt, išgirdau vieną duslų balsą. Ir štai atsikėlė vienas prietelis, mes atsikėlėm abudu, pradėjom vaikščiot po lavonų lauk,ą išgirdom duslų balsą. Išgirdę šį duslų balsą pribėgom, išgelbėjom tuojaus pulkininką Petruitį. Petruitis atsikėlė, mes tikiedamiesi, kad mes esam gyvi, yra dar ir daugiau gyvų, šaukėm ir vaikščiojom po minią, po ko.. šitą, lavonų lauką. Bet tuo momentu kitam krašte atsikėlė dar trys lietuviai ir du lenkai. Iš to dvylika šimtų mes atsikėlėm iš viso aštuoni žmonės, šeši lietuviai ir du lenkai. Paskiau, kada mes vaikščiojom tikiedamiesi surast daugiau ką nors, bet deja, tuo momentu enkavedistai pavažiavę toliau žemyn už krūmų laukė ir sekė mus. Pastebėję vaikščiojant žmones po lavonų lauką paleido mašiną ir kulkosvaidžių šūvius ir pradėjo važiuot artyn prie mūs, tikiedamiesi mus pagaut. Bet tuo momentu mes, k...kuomet jie paleido šūvius, nuo mūs buvo miškas maždaug du šimtai metrų, ir toj pusėj—kairėj pusėj kelio, ir čia grįžtant buvo rugių laukas. Per tą rugių lauką laimingai pasprukom apšaudomi į mišką. Ką bū darę toliau enkavedistai—aišku, būt mus ieškoję, bet tuo momentu užskrido vokiečių aviacijos lėktuvai, ir pradėjo apšaudyt jų mašinas.
David Boder: [In German] Ich will, dass Sie mir selbst erzählen sollen, was hat Ihnen persönlich– Ihnen selbst passiert, wenn die Deutschen nach Litauen gekommen sind.
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Ja dass ich komme...
David Boder: Sprechen Sie Litauisch. Aber Ihnen persönlich, Sie brauchen nicht die ganze Geschichte...wie ist es Ihnen gegangen? Ja, sprechen Deutsch.
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Deutsch. Ich kann sprechen Sie. Wir hatten gekommen zu mich—ich hatte gefangen. Ich dann ich kann sprechen—ich kann Sie sprechen über ich hatte gekommen zurück—von die Gefangen- welche haben gemacht und welchen Beruf—in Deutsch.
David Boder: Sprechen Sie Litauish.
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Gut, spreche ich Litauisch wieder.
Andrius Suvalkaitis: [In Lithuanian] Kuomet mes grįžom į Lietuvą, iš tos Červenės, jau radau vokiečius Lietuvoje. Vokiečiai Lietuvoj iš karto mums dar nieko ypatingo nedarė. Aš grįžęs iš karto gavau tarnybą, kepyklos vedėju. Dirbau kepykloj, po to perėjau į malūnų centrą. Malūnų centre buvau revizorium. Ir iš ten—patarnavau iki keturiasdešimts ketvirtų metų gegužės penkioliktos dienos. Gegužės penkioliktą dieną balševikai mane—ne tik mane, bet ir visus kitus—gaudydavo bažnyčiose ir išveždavo. Tuo pačiu sugavo ir mane ir atvežė į Vokietiją.
David Boder: [In German] Langsam.
Andrius Suvalkaitis: [In Lithuanian] Atvežė į Vokietiją, ir visą laiką turėjau dirbt prie apkasų, apkasų kasimuos. Dirbau Rytprūsiuos, ir taip palaipsniui atsiradau iki Karaliaučiaus. Nuo Karaliaučiaus iš apkasų pabėgau, atvažiavau į Berlyną, iš Berlyno pusės perėjęs į šią pusę mėnesį laiko—tai buvo kovo balandžio pradžia—mėnesį laiko pasi...pasislapščius pas ūkininkus, vieną kitą dieną padirbus, užėjo amerikiečiai. Užėjus amerikiečiams laimingai pakliuvau į Rytų lagerį ir šiandien dar tebegyvenu.
David Boder: [In German] Also, und wo waren Sie, wenn die Amerikaner gekommen?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Wenn die Amerikaner ersten gekommen..
David Boder: Litauisch.
Andrius Suvalkaitis: [In Lithuanian] Kai amerikonai atvažiavo, aš buvau Austrijoj.
David Boder: [In German] Und dann, wie sind Sie von Austria nach München gekommen?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: [In Lithuanian] O tai iš Austrijos aš tuojaus nuėjau į Militėrvojinimentą Zalcburge, prisistačiau ir ten jie mane tuojaus davė nurodymą, kad aš eič...eičiau į Zalcburgo Glazenbako bendrai visų tautybių surinkimo lagerį. Ten aš ir nuvykau, bet kuomet paaiškėjo, kad tas lageris yra tik tautoms, grįžtančioms į tėvynę, o aš į tėvynę grįžt dar nenorėjau tol, kol Lietuvoj bus balševykinė diktatūra, tai aš pa..paėmiau ir išvažiavau į Miuncheną. Atvažiavau į Miuncheną ir nuo praeitų birželio dvidešimts devintos dienos tebegyvenu Miunchene Didi lageryje.
David Boder: [In Russian] Ну а что вы думаете, у вас тут что, семья есть...в лагере, или вы один?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: [In German] Bitte sprechen Sie Deutsch.
David Boder: Ja ja. Haben Sie eine Familie im Lager oder sind Sie allein?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Nein, meine Familie ist in Litauer. Ich hab keine Familie. Ich bin verheiratet. Meine Frau und zwei Kinder es in Litauen.
David Boder: Haben sie geschrieben?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Nein, hat nicht geschrieben. Hat keine geschrieben. Meine Bruder von Amerika hat Brief geschrieben in Litauen, aber er hat nicht gekriegt.
David Boder: Hat keine Antwort bekommen?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Hab ich keine Antwort.
David Boder: Und was denken Sie wird jetzt weiter passieren? Was werden Sie tun?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Jetzt...
David Boder: Sie haben Bruder in Amerika.
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Ich habe Bruder und Schwester in Amerika.
David Boder: Werden die Sie rübernehmen?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Ja, ich habe jetzt Afidavit, aber ich weiß nicht, vielleicht ich kann nicht fahren in Amerika.
David Boder: Aha. Wenn Sie ein Afidavit haben, werden Sie schon bald fahren, in ein paar Monate vielleicht. Diesen Dienstag fahren 400 Menschen weg—vom anderen Lager.
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Na ja, die reste fahren. Ich auch jetzt hab Dienst—in Lager sind jetzt Ferien.
David Boder: Und was tun Sie jetzt hier?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Ich jetzt hier—ich bin jetzt Feuerwehrmann.
David Boder: Sie sind Feuerwehr. Was verstehen Sie zu tun? Weil womit können Sie was verdienen?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Ich bin Ökonomist– ich bin Buchhalter.
David Boder: Was heißt—Ökonomist?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: [In Lithuanian] Ekonomika.
Andrius Suvalkaitis: [In German] Litauisch—Buchhalter
David Boder: Aha, Sie haben Ökonomie studiert?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Ja.
David Boder: Wo?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: In Kaunas.
David Boder: In Kaunas. In der Universität. Oh. Wieviel Litauer sind hier in diesem Camp?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Hier? Ungefähr 800.
David Boder: 800 Litauer.
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Ja.
David Boder: Männer, Frauen und Kinder?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Ja, alles zusammen.
David Boder: Haben Sie eine Schule?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Ja, haben eine Schule.
David Boder: Eine litauische Schule?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Ja, eine litauische Schule. Und eine litauische Gymnasium. Und das ist...
David Boder: Und wo haben Sie Bücher bekommen?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Bücher? Jetzt...bisschen gekriecht von unseren Leuten, und geschickt jetzt aus Amerika.
David Boder: Und von Litauen haben Sie Bücher?
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Nein, von Litauen nein, von Litauen gar nicht mehr gekriegt.
David Boder: Also danke, Herr Suvalkaitis, das war ein sehr guter Report, und wir werden übersetzen lassen, und ich denke, wir werden sehr interessant, ihn sehr interessant finden.
Andrius Suvalkaitis: Danke.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes the report of Mr. Andrius Suvalkaitis, given mostly in Lithuanian, at Munich Baltic Center, at Lohengrinstrasse, September the 21st, 1946.